لاني لا تداعيات الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا في السادس من اشباط فبراير الجاري
اذا ارتفعت حصيله القتلى الى اكثر من
خمسين الفا بينما تم تسجيل اكثر من تسعه
الاف ومئه وسته وثلاثين هزه ارتداديه حتى
الان وقالت اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه افاد ان تركيا سجلت 44 الف ومئتين
وثمانيه عشره حاله وفاه بينما ارتفعت
حصيره قتل الزلزال في سوريا الى 5000
وتسعمائه
كما اعلنت في تركيا كذلك اداره الكوارث
والطوارئ افاد انا هزتين ارضيتين بقوه
اربع درجات وسبعه اعشار على مقياس رختر
لكل منهما وقعتا مساء الجمعه احداهما في
ولايه سواس وسط البلاد بينما الثانيه في
ولايه الجنوبيه البلاد واضافت انه بينما
تستمر عمليه رفع الانقاد من الولايات ال11
المتضرره فانه تم اجلاء اكثر من نصف مليون
مواطن من المناطق المنكوبه الى مناطق اكثر
امنا
في سياق المتصل قال وزير البيئه التركي
مراد كرم ان حكومته انجزت قرابه 80 الى
90% من جهود معينه الاضرار الناتجه عن
الزلزال مؤكدا ان 90% من المباني والمنازل
في المناطق المنكوبه اما قد انهار او تعرض
لاضرار كبيره